what's the scoop okay the scoop is will
I can say which F every announcement
panel but anyway um it's this guy Alexia
szostak off and he's also known as the
red Guardian yeah so you can look him up
in the Marvel comic universe he is in
the Cold War there was a nuclear arms
race and they the Americans developed
all these armaments including Captain
America and the Soviets retaliated by
creating their own version called the
red Guardian and he's but he's somewhat
different than Captain America and he's
uh he's very complicated guy and that's
where like I love about it like he you
know when it was pitched to me early on
is by this director Kate Shortland it
was it was pitched as you know she sort
of told me about this thing in the
center I was excited about the certain
version and then she told me like he's
completely surprising personality quirks
and character traits that were
completely counter to what I expected a
character like this to be and so in that
way you know these Marvel guys are the
Cadillac of the she universe because
it's not because they do things it's big
it's because they're so smart about the
way they have their twists and turns and
how smart and rich the characters are
you know the flaws and something like
Iron Man like his arrogance and
you know but then his heart underneath
that is like you go on this journey with
his characters and Alexei you know he's
a tremendously flawed guy and he also
has tremendous humor tremendous heart so
he's a really complicated guy I'm really
excited for you to see him is he a daddy
I mean if you're gonna cast David Harbor
then yes do we have our new man sir
thank you so much
[Music]